yeah I wanted to make it simple here for
everyone to understand we're gonna bring
up the ingredients in this deal you've
got Heinz which was taken private by 3G
and Berkshire in 2013 and then you've
got Kraft a slower growing less exciting
North America snack focused business I
was split off from the more exciting
Mondelez plus you've got ten billion
dollars in capital from 3G and Buffett
all that combined will become the Kraft
Heinz Company a publicly traded company
with an enterprise value of about a
hundred billion dollars the theater
braddock all value in a takeover mat
what is each side getting this deal I
know that Kraft shareholders are getting
what 49% of the company yes we're
getting a little bit ahead of ourselves
but yes Buffett and 3G get a controlling
51% stake Kraft shareholders get 49%
they get one share of the combined
company for every existing Kraft chair
they own plus a special dividend of 1650
a share that is funded by that ten
billion dollars kicked in from Buffett
and 3G so yes while they get a minority
stake they get the premium that 1650
cash payment plus they get to retain
their dividend plus they get to share in
the synergies which is about one and a
half billion dollars annually by 2017
and maybe this one is you can't quantify
it the benefit of the company being
owned by what many people would argue
would be the two best investors of the
world 3G capital and Warren Buffett I'd
Skaar I know you've been talking to
people on the street Jay what are they
saying about the deal yeah at Hammond of
our M&A team had called it complex
I spoke with Sachin shot the merger arm
strategist at Albert Frieden company he
said this is not M&A 101 this is
advanced mergers because typically when
you've got a PE firm involved it's
usually to take a company private cut
cost and then add debt and then
eventually IPO the business what you
have here instead is Buffett in three
key effectively taking Heinz public by
reversing craft into Heinz which is a
private company who that will then use
the deal to go public and control the
new company which is why it's
interesting that the company is called
Kraft Heinz maybe it's an appeasement to
management as for the debt this is where
a lot of people are complimenting Warren
Buffett and three key for being pretty
clever because Heinz is going to
refinance its high-yield debt with
investment grade debt pay
backing off of crafts investment grade
rating and therefore lower borrowing
costs though we should mention that SP
said the new company would have a triple
B - rating the lowest investment grade
and it's put crafts and hides on review
for possible downgrade I'm gonna say
craft x is a bid to appease the consumer
right because you don't care if you buy
Kraft Heinz ketchup but you don't want
to buy Heinz Kraft macaroni and cheese
Kraft is the more important I don't know
I don't I don't think about that
necessarily
I suppose that's its Heinz ketchup more
attractive to the consumer it's only
something you have on the side whereas
Kraft is like a main course it's the
more important I would say name even
though Heinz is gonna run the company
Heinz is gonna buy the company
eventually they'll probably shut down
Kraft headquarters it's clearly to
Canada in spying Kraft even though we
like to throw around the horrible word
merger scarlet thanks so much Kraft is
still attractive that they had to split
it up from Mondelez which was even more
attractive with its higher growth rate
so he could argue both ways